at any given moment we humans have two  choices or two spirals that are  available to us the first is the toilet  Vortex the toilet Vortex might start  like this you're picking on yourself  because you don't like the way you look  in the mirror you're unhappy with your  level of productivity or you have failed  to achieve ketosis whatever and then you  take that out on other people  and then you are feeling more miserable  and then down you go the vastly superior  alternative is what I call the cheesy  upward spiral as your inner weather gets  bombier that shows up in your  relationships with other people and  because relationships are probably the  most important variable when it comes to  human flourishing your inner weather  improves even further  and up you go and that is the whole  point here self-love properly understood  not as narcissism but as having your own  back is not selfish it makes you better  at loving other people and that makes  you more generous and more available